Did you know that My Hero Academia
Swept the Crunchyroll Anime Awards last year? Out of 17 categories,
It was nominated in eight and it won seven!!. It's like the La-La-Land of ANIME except,
You know... it's actually good
And it's not a poorly written,POORLY composed
Poorly summed musical with TIRED themes that pander to the egoism of Hollywood oof, huh, that's sorry
I uh...really let myself get carried away there. (yep)Let's talk about anime
#AWESOME INTRO#
Hello Internet welcome to Film Theory!The show that's dedicated to RUINING your favorite superheroes one by one.
So far we've killed off Luke Cage, Deadpool, Spider-man, Magneto and Wolverine. We've taken away Dr. Strange's magic
We've wrecked Thor's self-esteem (ROASTED)
We've exposed Batman and Wonder Woman for the failures that they are. (yep)We've proved that Ant Man and Superman would destroy the world
We've pitted The Incredibles against each other! and just last month..
I showed you how Black Panthers biggest weakness was the law of Supply and Demand!
But today!Instead of just looking at more Marvel and DC superheroes we're instead turning our eyes
Eastward, to tackle the insanely popular Anime "My Hero Academia"
Where superheroes aren't masked vigilantes with Secret Identities,
But instead government sanctioned Professionals who work full-time saving lives while employed by various hero agencies
And it's not just the heroes who have the superpowers here!! 80% of the population has some sort of unique power called a quirk
Reports of people with superpowers popped up across the globe for long the
supernatural became the totally normal Quirks range from mostly useless physical deformities to insane
supernatural abilities like converting body fat into synthetic matter sweating nitroglycerin!
shooting laser beams out of your belly button or tape out of your elbows!!
No, joke those are both real superpowers in the series(woow i must watch it now) overall there are any number of interesting quirks to explore throughout this series
,But today. I want to look a bit closer at the show's most important hero
All Might ,the world's symbol of peace and#1 most POWERFUUUL
Superhero now being so highly ranked would lead you to assume that all might was born with the most
amazing Quirk of all time
But that actually couldn't be further from the truth....
His Quirk named: "one for all' was actually given to him in a world where practically
Everyone is born with a superpower all might just wasn't(hello darkness my old friend...)before being given to one for all power. He had no quirk
"I was Quirkless too as a kid" in fact all might was the 8th person to receive the "OFA" trait and the
Story of My Hero Academia is all about him passing it on to its 9th user the series protagonist
De
Deku another person born without a Quirk just like All Might himself
"I deEm you WorthAy of mEH poWer my Quirk is yourZ to inherit"
This is all well and good the characters are all super lovable the story is super compelling..... except for one thing
It's my theory that ALL MIGGHT was
Born with a Quirk if you look at the series lore and the way the one-for-all Quirk behaves all might
Possesses a latent Quirk beyond just one for all that maybe even he was never aware of and I'm about to lay down that evidence
For you after all as they say on the show meddling when you don't need to is the essence of being a hero
That must mean I'm a hero then right?(Sorry but,no)
Maybe my Quirk is the incredible ability to JUMP to conclusions ( get it?)
To begin we need to look a bit closer at the range of quirks present in this universe you see the my hero quirks fall
into one of three broad category types
Transformation Mutant and Emitter Transformation type Quirks as the name implies
Transform or change the form of the user's body in some way
Or adds a new feature to the users body for a limited amount of time, for example one transformation Quirk gives the user the power
To harden any part of their body thereby increasing its
Resistance and defensive capabilities another possessed by the character mount lady is able to transform into a giant version of herself pretty self-explanatory
Moving on Mutant type Quirks unlike Transformations are permanent changes to the user's physiology
These are quirks like Frappys frog form Ogiros tail and Tohru's invisibility these quirks can't be turned off and then finally there's the emitter
Type Quirks which are pretty much everything else they're defined as being
Activation based so they can be turned on and off and unlike the other two categories emitter Quirks
Don't actually alter the user's appearance instead the users just able to generate
substances or change certain materials around them at will this includes everything from
Emitting an aroma that puts people to sleep to emitting sweat that happens to explode more unusual examples of emitter quirks belong to showTazawa
who can cancel the quirks of others just by looking at them and to toshishinso who can brainwash anyone who answers one
Of his questions thereby forcing them to do what he says and between those three
Classifications that encompasses all known Quirks in this universe equipped with that knowledge now
Let's examine all might's Quirk one for all even though
It's technically one Quirk one for all is actually a combination of two very separate powers first a Quirk that
Stockpiles power much like a battery storing energy and second a Quirk that can be passed on to others
Just like the passing of a torch as a result of this odd
Combination of powers one for all makes each new person to inherit it stronger than the last!
one person who proves the power than hands it off to another person it continues to grow as its passed along
It's how All Might user No:8 is able to be the uncontested greatest hero in the world, and how Deku all might's
Successor presumably rises to that exact same status hence the story of My Hero Academia
This is the story of how I became the world's greatest hero, but here's where things start to get suspicious
This is all might's body when he's not using the Quirk
And this is his body when he is using the Quirk now based on these images
You would think that one for all would be classified as a Transformation style Quirk right all might's body is clearly undergoing a huge
Transformation every time he activates the power growing in size and muscle mass ( DEM 20 BICEPS)by like a hundredfold
But it's not the manga very explicitly classifies it as an emitter style Quirk, which again
we just reviewed and are defined by not altering the user's appearance now that might seem like it's a really minor distinction a
Really small nit to pick as to how this Quirk works
But then look at this! when Deku uses one for all his body doesn't change
He remains the lean scrawny kid that we've seen throughout the series and before you ask no
That's not just because he's only using 5% of one for all's power in the manga even when Deku pushes his power output over
20% we still don't see any signs of Deku's muscles growing AT ALL!
And this is a very MINOR spoiler for the manga, so if you don't want to be spoiled just skip ahead a few seconds
But shortly beyond where we've seen in the show Deku is able to temporarily use a hundred percent and even an incredible 1
Million percent of one for alls power and yet his body still remains the same
It's also worth noting that all might's size doesn't equate to his strength again mild spoilers ahead
but in Chapter
95 of the manga we see what happens when all might gives up one for all he has a few embers of his former power
Left but they get used up he specifically says early on in the chapter the Embers inside me have vanished later
He talks more about it to Deku the embers of one-for-all inside me are gone
And what's more I can't maintain my muscle form anymore now this tells us two interesting things first the way
This is phrased implies that his muscle form and One-for-all are two different things one for all is gone
But also I can't maintain my muscle form anymore
We also see him briefly transform into muscle form in these panels only to revert immediately back
But again if one for all were his only quirk and the embers were truly burned out like he says earlier in the chapter well then
He shouldn't be able to do that
transformation at all !all of this would seem to suggest that all might wasn't born Quirkless that he possessed some sort of
Transformation ability BEFORE he inherited one for all if you need more proof just look at how grantorino all might's trainer
describes his early days with Hiro
He was pretty much able to use one for all right off the bat, of course he had the body going for him
So there's that the scene then cuts to a young all might getting trained and his body looks no different than Deku's he's still
Relatively skinny he's not super buff
And that's not all while discussing Deku's strength training all might even says to him
Offhandedly that for some reason he was able to access a hundred percent of one-for-all's power as soon as he inherited it
That's a weirdly specific detail to include isn't it
that means that there has to be something that set all might apart from Deku and allowed him to handle
All that excess energy when Deku can't despite both of them supposedly starting off Quirkless
So what would be so special and?
Significantly different about all might's body that would enable him to use powers right away without a Quirk that would differentiate him from Deku
It's hard to imagine an actual
Explanation here all of it seems to point to all might having some sort of hidden Quirk before he actually inherited one for all
And it's not like latent undiscovered Quirks are unheard of in this universe in fact the very
Origin of one for all exists in an undiscovered almost vestigial quirk one for all was originally created by a villain named
AFO
And if you think that gets confusing it does all for one's Quirk allowed him to transfer quirks between other
People now all for one's brother was seemingly born Quirkless so all for one gave his brother a quirk that allowed him to store
up power however
Unknown to all for one his brother actually did have a Quirk one that allowed him to pass his quirks on to other
People it would have been totally useless on its own, but with the new quirk
That was added by his brother those two Quirks combined to create one for all this evil man had a Quirkless younger brother even though
Everyone thought he was Quirkless
turns out the brother did have a quirk he had a useless power that only allowed him to pass on quirks and
SO the stockpiling ability merged with the younger brothers power
And that is how one for all came to be so it's already canon that there can be latent or hidden
Quirks in people so why not all might's
Here's the thing when you look at how it operates one for all
Isn't about muscle strength sure Deku needs the strength and up for ten months so inheriting the quirk doesn't destroy his limbs
an unprepared body can't fully inherit it your arms and legs would shoot off if you tried to. SERIOUSLY!?
Which in and of itself is a bit weird to begin with right? if all might were indeed
Quirkless to begin with and then receive the power and could suddenly use one for all from the get-go
Wouldn't he just be under the impression that Deku could handle it as well anyway the actual power of one for all isn't
Mechanical power coming from muscles it actually works by storing up metabolic energy converting it to kinetic energy
And then channeling that energy through the body
It's pretty easy to see this in action in Episode two we see all might punch so hard that it changes the weather pure super
Strength isn't gonna do that you also see it in Deku when Deku uses one for all we see the air around him
Crackling with green energy. That's not just for show
That's the excess energy of his Quirk
overflowing from his body the same doesn't happen to all might because his
Biceps are actually beefy enough to contain all of it inside him in which seems to indicate that perhaps all might's latent
Transformation quirk is to expand his muscles without really increasing his overall strength
It's a seemingly useless quirk unless he inherits something that requires his body to store huge amounts of energy
Just like the creation of one for all to begin with a useless
Quirk on its own that becomes super powerful when combined with exactly the right
complementary work
But lastly think about this before all might pass the Quirk on Deku the only goal of one for all users
Passing on their power was to eventually create a superhero capable of taking down all for one that insanely powerful
Evil brother who literally had access to all the super powers in the world now with that as a pretty
important goal would anyone in their right
mind entrust that power to someone with no
Quirk of their own and thus no power of their own ?!if you're looking to keep hope alive that you'll defeat the world's strongest
Supervillain that just wouldn't make any sense no the far more likely scenario
Is that all might was chosen for his Quirk a Quirk that enabled him to be a bigger more powerful?
battery someone that was perfectly suited to use the power of one for all
Before inheriting one for all all might believed that he had no Quirk
He said as much to Deku who found it hugely inspirational to hear that his hero
Also started out as a weak powerless Quirkless person
but for as inspiring as a story as that is it's still just a story if you actually stop and look at the
classification of the Quirk how it behaves and even the
Motivations of the heroes passing one for all on all might must have had a Quirk before inheriting it from his predecessor
At best he wasn't aware of it until he acquired one for all at worst
He outright lied to Deku in an effort to push his apprentice to new and even more impressive
Heights or who knows maybe season 3 will prove me completely wrong?, but hey
that's just a theory A FILM THEORY and
speaking of season 3
It's going on right NOW(OH NO AN AD!), and who doesn't love watching the creators of a series decimate my theories in real time, but matpat
It's only airing in Japan and I can't speak Japanese ( I DONT CARE, GO LEARN IT)
All those new All Might memes that are gonna be circulating on Twitter are going to pass me by oh no my friends you too
Can watch season 3 eat away at my theory and be hit with all the new Mimi's as they're happening live with VRV
That's right!! all three seasons of my hero academia are available subbed if you're a purist or dubbed if you hate
reading
Right on VRV with each new episode of season three going up every Saturday starting
Well this past Saturday! (yaaay GO BUY STUFF!)
So don't wait if you're not on VRV already you're already falling behind the season for a limited time theorists
Just like you watching right now can get a 30-day free trial of VRV premium (ooowwo sounds cool!)
Which gives you ad free access to 13 channels including Crunchyroll(TM)
Roosterteeth Funimation(TM) and Cartoon Hang Over by going to VRV dotco
Slash matpat link is down below in the description and like you heard with both
Crunchyroll and Funimation and the VRV family VRV is gonna be your go-to place for all the must watch anime including Cowboy Bebop
Which just celebrated its 20 year anniversary a few days ago now if you haven't seen Cowboy Bebop
It's actually one of my first ever introductions to ANIME it is a must watch for a reason
This is one of the anime that all other anime are built upon (OMG THE MORE YOU LEARN!)
Or if you're interested in something a bit newer VRV also
Just got the first
53 episodes of Dragon Ball super dubbed so as a pleb who admittedly enjoys watching the dubs more than the subs
I'm finally gonna get my chance to catch up on all that Goku black
Business because you know apparently you can never have enough Goku unless of course you're talking about Dragon Ball GT
But you know don't talk about Dragon Ball GT plus best of all VRV allows you to download
episodes to your mobile device so you can watch it all without an internet connection
Which I gotta say has been a big reason why I was able to do this theory on My Hero Academia today
Binging MHA on a plane over to VidCon Europe was a godsend
14 hours of travel fly by when you're watching a guy with exploding sweat duke it out against a guy who breaks his fingers like
every other episode
So anyway save your data catch up on some awesome anime and even find some new shows that you'll love on some of the other
VRV channels, try it all out for the next 30 days with VRV premium at VRV
dot Co slash
matpat use those quirky awesome engine legs to rush down into the
Description and click that link now if you'll excuse me
I need to actually go download some more anime because I have another long plane ride that I've got tonight
There's been way too much travel in the first couple months of this year
but uh
It's finally starting to end so hopefully I'll be at home for a while getting able to do some GT lives
But uh, holy jeez there's been a lot of travel
It's gotten me caught up on a lot of anime you can do it do click the link\